well welcome everybody to the meeting of
the accounts and audit committee on the
second of february 22.
um
our first item is uh attendances
um any apologies
apologies from council accordingly thank
you i've not said bull roll here i think
apart from council accordingly
quick item two's questions from members
of the public uh joe there any
thank you very much no no questions item
three's declarations of interest
members to give notice we're all
familiar with that procedure i'm sure
item four is the minutes of the meeting
on the 25th of november
2021 can we agree those was a correct
record for those who are there
thanks thank you
item five is a star
um procurement update from uh lorraine
cox who's uh managed to get here through
the traffic jam
so you obviously got slides lorraine so
we'll move out of your way so he can do
that
[Music]
okay i'll make a start thank you chair
and just to introduce myself again i'm
lorene cox i'm the director of star
procurement um just in case we've got
any members here that haven't heard me
speak before um star procurement is a
shared service hosted by trafford
council so if you just try and view us
as a council department we just happen
to be four councils departments for
procurement and obviously we work in a
collaborative way across those four main
councils
um
we're actually eight years old this week
so that's how long we've been around so
i think that's a good sign
um
just who are we we work for trafford
rochdale thameside and stockport
councils we also work for two clinical
commissioning groups including traffords
we also lead probably about 70 percent
of the collaborative procurement
activity across the tent council across
greater manchester and sometimes that
involves the clinical commissioning
groups at the moment too
and we also do a number of regional and
national commissions which brings income
into star and obviously that helps them
to support the four councils
particularly trafford so we work
regionally and nationally but as i say
that's more of a traded service
in terms of our business plan we have
something called the five c's the five
objectives which um we think about our
role is rather than just thinking of it
as buying and doing the the procurement
bit but we actually try and think about
communities how does the decision-making
process how does the thought process how
does the actual commercial process of
what we do impact on the communities
particularly you know the people that we
serve within this particular borough we
think about it commercially because
ultimately we're here to save you money
reduce costs bring efficiencies and so
commerciality is really really key in
everything that we do
we look at collaboration clearly we're
an evidence of of collaboration the fact
that the four councils work together and
have done for eight years now and what
we always try and do first is say can we
collaborate rather than do a contract
for a sole organization because there's
efficiencies that come with that
we've got provide confidence um very
important that particularly with an
audit committee um it's about making
sure that you are compliant both with
your own constitution with regulations
nationally and internationally as we sit
at the moment but we do know that we've
got new regulations coming in the green
paper which will um be enforced if
that's the right term in um 2023 so we
are at the cusp of moving forwards in
procurement in terms of our regulations
and the statute that drives us and
there's some significant changes coming
um next year and when i next come to
talk to you i'd really like to take you
through those so you can understand the
impact because there's a lot around
localism leveling up opportunities for
volunteering community sectors and i
think it's really really important that
members are clear on what that brings
and and how much freedom and flexibility
that can provide for us to do even more
and then the last one is be courageous
um
i don't know where that word came from
but it's just about as big bold really
and just challenging the norm and i
think that the privilege of working
across four organizations is is i
certainly get for lots of thinking when
i'm with board and joint committee we
think about what's important to the
individual organization but also the
collective and it's about just taking a
little bit of a risk obviously within
the rules but to actually say can we do
something that's different and that's
better and it's a great test bed
environment to be honest with you to
work within so that's what being
courageous is all about
we have four enablers one is leadership
and governance
i have a star board that sits alongside
me graeme bentley and will be joining us
soon to replace jane and for trafford
and in terms of the governance we have a
delegated committee and we have council
ross that represents trafford on the
star delegated committee the other
enablers are technology and data we're
always trying to improve what we do and
use the tools that we've got in front of
us
and we've moved quite massively over the
last few years in the use of technology
and data
communication engagement's important
because not only is it important for me
to make sure officers and members are
working in the right way but actually
we've got to look at the business
communities and equally we've got to
look at the communities who we actually
serve because ultimately we need to buy
things that are actually having the
right impact and the best outcome for
the people on the streets of your
borough and the last one is talent
management and i can't do what i do
without my 40 people and we have a big
grow your own policy and we have a
massive retention
and success story within star and and we
do see people go from apprenticeship
right up to sort of senior positions
within star and i think hr always say to
us you know we should copy some of what
star does because we definitely retain
our people because there's good career
development that comes from that larger
organization and that shared
organization
just in terms of our performance last
year
obviously we're due to close at the end
of march again and i'm hoping these
numbers will be even higher i'll just
pick a couple out if i may um
the in-year savings for last year across
the four councils was a collective 6.1
million and that is cashable cutable
savings that get given back so to speak
declared back to the four individual
councils and what we do is we work with
graham's team in trafford to ratify
those savings so a question i think i
got asked at stockport not so long ago
was was who sort of does the the
homework mark's your homework lorraine i
think was the question and that is done
by graham's team who look at budgets
they look at obviously predicted um
savings and cost reductions through good
procurement so that's where the 6.1
million comes from and we deliver
roughly about that amount of money year
on year we had one spike here of about
about nine million i think where we
landed quite a big contract in stockport
but we're on average um delivering about
six million
in terms of return on investment um
approximately every year for every pound
trafford council pays into star you get
four pounds back of cashable savings so
that's the return on investment that we
deliver as a sort of a business unit
um social value i think we talked about
last time
last year we delivered 28
of added value so again for every pound
that you're spending on your contracts
on average across the star family of
four we were seeing 28 pence back of
extra added value coming from social
value so again nationally we're the best
in the country in terms of our social
value return which i'm really proud of
um we've won a number of awards again um
we as i say we lead about 75 of the
collaborative activity across greater
manchester so we do influence other
councils as well um we've not yet
persuaded them to join the staff family
but i'm working on it but at the moment
you know we're very robust and quite
confident in what we do
so the important bit i want to take you
through some numbers if i can today um
do you want me to just switch the lights
a little bit it's oh they thank you
is that a bit better sorry i couldn't
see that properly so if i just take you
through some numbers i'll talk you
through them so you can follow me um
this is this is trafford only this isn't
star because it's really important that
you understand the numbers for your
organization
what we've looked at is if you look at
the blue column in the middle the 2021
for the last financial year your total
spend was 626 million pounds and what we
do is we extract what we call a
controllable spend element so that's
basically the money that trafford
council spends with third parties
so anything that goes out of the borough
so staffing won't be in that um things
like social care payments in terms of
foster care that sort of thing won't be
within that fund but it's actually 244
million that you actually spend on on
your contract to spend your third party
spend within that year
what i like to do is obviously compare
and contrast over the three years so
those of you that were here last year
would have seen um
17 18 on that slide and i've just moved
it along to give you a three-year
position
and it does fluctuate massively because
it depends obviously what what schemes
are going on if you've got capital
projects within the borough um sometimes
you know graham's team and myself we
look at what's in the controllable and
non-controllable and the figures do move
so i wouldn't get sort of too hung up on
on why the percentage changes across the
year it's just illustrative just so you
know what the bit is i can touch so i
can touch in theory the 244
million of controllable spend in 2021
moving down to the line where it says
local borough on the left-hand side um
again if i move you to the the turquoise
column in the middle what that is
showing is um we measure how much of
your contracted spend gets spent within
the trafford borough
which for last year it was 97.3 million
and we then say how much of it was spent
if it didn't land in trafford how much
of it landed within greater manchester
and that was 78 million and obviously
the balancing figure of spend was
actually 65 million spent nationally the
reason that's important to me is is one
of the performance targets i have that i
report back to star joint committee is
to look at how we get trafford's money
spent in trafford it does fluctuate as
you can see we've gone 49 49 and we've
dipped 40 last year um i'm not concerned
about that but it's really important
that members are aware of it in order
that you you keep on my back and make
sure that i look at why
and what we're doing at the moment is
scrutinizing that figure to say
what what is the reason and what you
tend to find is it may be that the type
of spend or the contracts that are
expired within that year
have have not for some reason been able
to land within the borough it may be
that there isn't a contractor within
your trafford borough that can actually
deliver the type of contract that you've
actually um procured last year so that
fluctuation of nine percent for me isn't
causing me concern but it's one to watch
and one for me to keep an eye on for
when i come back next year and tell you
about 21.22
and you will see that the contained
within gm has increased so again if the
contractor that has won hasn't been in
trafford there is an increase in an
improvement of the money that's landed
within greater manchester and for me
because i wear four hats and work for
for authorities if i can't land your
contracts in trafford clearly the next
target for me is to london within
greater manchester so i think there is a
good news story there that 78 million
pound some has landed within greater
manchester and obviously we look at what
goes out of out of borough and out of
greater manchester region um which again
has increased but bear in mind the
funding envelope from the line at the
top of the controllable spend has
increased significantly last year so
again that might have skewed why those
figures have changed slightly
the line at the bottom is about on
contract spend again from an audit point
of view what you need is to make sure
that your officers are are operating
within your rules the constitution and
indeed with the the public contract
regulations um 90 is the best in terms
of my four councils and for me it's more
than satisfactory in terms of a
compliant way of procuring the sorts of
activities that won't be clusters as
compliant will be things like where
officers have put a waiver in where
they've used the rules to actually say
we need to maybe extend a contract
period because we're looking at maybe
aligning different contracts and
bringing contracts together either
within the authority or with other
partner organizations that may be that
they want to say well we've actually got
a review taking place so can we extend
the existing provider and and keep that
in place for a period of time so they
utilize things called exemptions waivers
and modifications to actually enact
those changes but they will be clusters
as off contracts so to speak or outside
of the rules so the compliance for me is
important but you are you're absolutely
on target i would say with a 90 percent
performance
just another slide on on data um what i
wanted to do was just take you through
your social value performance now again
if i just may explain social value again
forgive me because i know some members
might not have heard this before social
value is about what we ask contractors
to provide on top of actually responding
to the specification that we require
through our procurement process and we
have something called themes outcomes
and measures which i think mark
circulated at the last meeting which is
basically a long list of elements of
social value that contractors can offer
us things like apprenticeships they
could look at actually saying well i'm
going to commit 50 of the supply chain
spend within the borough they could say
things like i'm going to work with
homeless cohort of people to get them
back into work and do some training in
education they could say we're going to
work with care leavers to help with
transition so the big long list of toms
we have and that's what we issue through
the procurement process for contractors
to select from that
what we're working on at the moment
first of all is to create a trafford
version of the toms because what's more
important for me now as we move forward
is we actually get the right social
value for trafford rather than what
contractors want to give us
so historically and to date we've
basically said that's the menu tell us
what you're going to give us and
obviously we've used that in the
evaluation what we're moving to now and
working closely with colleagues across
traffic is to actually say what is it
that trafford residents need what do
travis businesses need and actually to
target those toms in order that the
social value is what you need in
trafford rather than what as i say the
contractors want to give
but the good news story is if you look
at the performance lines down below and
i've put it in blue for you
in 1920s star across the four councils
secured 25
of added value on top of the contract
value that they're actually expending
across as i say across the four council
so for every pound the four councils
have spent on contracting they've got 25
percent sorry 25 pence have added value
in 2021 we managed to increase that up
to 28
and currently to date it's only a
quarter two so that's a half year report
we're actually averaging about 35
percent across the star family so
whatever we're doing on the social value
campaign it's definitely working
and even more importantly the trafford
numbers are absolutely the best they are
the best for me at the moment we did
30.5 in 1920 that went to 67.1 percent
there was a couple of very large
contracts last year and i think sale
magistrates was one really good case
study of where we got a lot of
additional social value through that
procurement and to date at quarter two
you're looking at 52 percent um that's
exceeding the expectation nationally
nationally and i sit on a national
social value task force with local
government association cabinet office
and people like that um they were
expecting us to deliver about 25
was the target for 2025 and we're only
at 20 21 22 and we're already exceeding
that that expectation considerably so
for me the approach we've taken for
social value um which was brave and it
was a decision taken by joint committee
three years ago it's absolutely working
but what i want to do for members for
trafford and for the other boroughs is
to actually now flip it on its head and
say can i bring the right social value
into your borough because i want to hit
the needs and the wants of your people
your businesses and and to help the
economic the social and the
environmental improvements within the
borough rather than the businesses
dictating
just
one last slide for me and
something we launched a few months ago
through starjoint committee was was 12
steps to social value and
what i wanted to do was to say right
we've done a lot so far so actually what
are we going to work on over the next 12
months 18 months and what we've
recognized is it's important that we
help bidders to be better so what i mean
by that is firstly we look at data we
look at how many volunteering community
sector people bid we are now recording
um
black and ethnic businesses we are
starting to consider whether we should
look at women in leadership roles in
business and actually look at those
diverse characteristics to say
how many are bidding and how many are
winning because i always believe if
you've got a baseline and a starting
point you can at least evidence
hopefully some improvement but to make
them better what we need to do and what
we have been doing is investing time in
making sure we do early engagement with
businesses we're making sure that we're
giving plenty of time to the market
because if you particularly want your
small and medium enterprises your
volunteering community sectors to bid
they need more time than the big boys
and girls who have teams of people in
offices who can rattle off tenders right
left and center so there's a big turn in
the way we're approaching this to try
and help particularly the small mediums
and the voluntary and community sectors
to bid by giving them more time giving
them access making sure we're doing
briefing sessions before we even go out
to market in order that they can ask us
honest and open questions in an
environment before in a live tender
process
and the second one along is just around
the policy and law as i've mentioned
we've got new regulations coming out in
2023 and we've got something called mpps
which is the national procurement policy
statement which is i suppose a
preamble if that's the right word to the
regulations and and what we've done is
we've looked at what they think is going
to come in the new regulations and we've
actually rag rated star and our
performance against that and most of
those things are green um and a few
ambers but we're actually progressing
quite rapidly um in terms of making
ourselves ready for when the regulations
land next year we want to remove
barriers i think that probably links
very closely to number one and we still
make it hard and clunky and i think we
could do things in a more simpler way so
i've got a team that are working on what
we call simplify to actually say how can
we make that tender process quicker and
slicker and simpler in order that we're
not bureaucratic and make it too
challenging for particularly the small
enterprises um social value as an
organization i know the leader of
trafford has been very keen to um look
at becoming a social value organization
um
and i know you you as a borough are
looking at things like real living wage
looking at possibly your planning
applications but actually what other
decision points do you have within your
borough that you can actually apply your
thinking around social value because
it's not just procurement where you can
get social value gains from and i know
particularly corporate management team
and certainly councillor ross who
represents you at star is looking to see
how that can be pushed into the
organization rather than it just being
seen as something you do in procurement
middle line local spend we've talked
about
second box along we're just refreshing
our um social value strategy at the
moment um and responsible procurement
strategy because again there's lots of
stuff that's coming out from central
government in terms of how we should
look at you know the wider sector of
things around modern slavery
looking at obviously making sure that
we're inclusive in terms of the diverse
um supply chains so um we're making sure
that strategy is current and refreshed
key priorities we've got the 2038 carbon
um neutral target for greater manchester
so again how can procurement help that
but for me it's also the balance between
i don't want to mandate something that
then will stop small and medium
enterprises and the smes from bidding
because it's too hard and they haven't
got the infrastructure so i've got to
balance some of the targets that we
build into the process to make sure
we're not sort of adversely
discriminated against the sectors that
we want to bid and win
an annual statement is about where you
have an audit statement and obviously a
year-end set of accounts but actually um
we've got a template now from one
council down in in hammersmith it
actually is in in london um who have
actually done a declaration of what
their social value um statement is at
year end and and we've just recently got
hold of the template and again i've
pushed that through to offices to say is
this something we should consider for
the four councils because i think if you
publish where you're at and particularly
because you're in such a strong position
in trafford i think it would be a good
news story and it also keeps me clean
because i've got to keep performing and
making sure that i'm maintaining that
that success
the bottom line is is challenging the
supply chain for me it's not just about
who we give what we call the tier one
contract too but actually where are
their supply chains coming from are they
buying local are they employing local
people are they actually looking belong
beyond so actually that pound that you
spend into that first tier one
contractor how is he or she spending
that with the same ethos as they move
through the delivery of that contract
point so that's really really important
and one that we need to really focus on
um
the next box i've talked about fred and
bob and sue i think i call it but it's
actually about how does all of this
actually impact on on the people on the
streets of your borough because
ultimately i can bring apprenticeships
in i can bring um you know employment in
through social value and procurement but
are we actually getting the right people
into employment and the most vulnerable
groups into employment so it's actually
working with officers within the council
to say how do we target some of your key
priorities and keywords and borrowers
that need that support
and the third one is about how we sorry
third one across is about how we manage
and report social value and graham very
kindly supported me recently with doing
a review of the tool that we use which
is the social value portal um and we're
just about to take a paper to star joint
committee and hopefully in the next few
weeks to look at a community impact fund
to see whether we can actually get some
return and investment back from from
that portal and group that actually
administered that system for us and then
the last one is about looking at this
from a place-based um
approach and what i mean by that is
obviously my job is to support trafford
council but actually what's going on
within your borough in terms of other
institutions other public sector people
with public money but actually equally
what about the private sector that's in
your borough and how can we work more
effectively and i've spoken to diane
geary on this one and she's looking at
partnership groups and events that she
hosts and coordinates for trafford to
see whether we can start to infiltrate
and actually explain what we do with
star procurement and see whether we can
get some of the partner anchor
institutions within the borough to work
more closely together so that's what the
last one is about
chair i'm happy to take questions thank
you
thanks lorraine for that very impressive
particular social value
factors of it are there any questions
for anybody
councillor carter first oh
gospel jerome then comes to carter
thanks chair and
thank you for that presentation really
informative um i was just wondering on
the
sustainability in carbon neutral
um
are you saying to company you said you
had to balance it and there are smaller
companies that maybe
do you tell them that maybe that we've
got a trajectory that where they might
need to improve their contract over time
and also is it who's pressuring you to
do better on that
thank you councillor good questions and
we're at the early stages of carbon i'm
just going to declare that i am not a
carbon expert other than obviously what
i practice in my my own home and own
sort of behaviors and so what we're
doing is working with sustainability
officers within this organization and
certainly across the star family to
actually understand what carbon target
should be and could be and equally we
sit on a national um carbon group a
procurement carbon group to actually
learn um from key speakers that come and
work with us and obviously officers that
work in other organizations across the
country nationally
for me and we know that collectively um
we've got the 2038 target for greater
manchester um there were other targets
and i think the leader was um i think he
was on
the was he on the green um
gm
group was it the clean air um forgive me
i can't remember the name of it but i
know it's it's it's important for the
leader and obviously it's important for
the council as part of that gm family so
what we want to look at is is what can
we put in a tender process
that firstly enables you know good
practice to help with that regional
target but equally what do we need
within trafford um again once we start
to look at the tom's measures there are
a set in there of about half a dozen um
national measures and what we want to do
is to say for trafford are they relevant
are they what you need and we will be
doing consultation with obviously key
members and officers as well to make
sure that's done in the right way in
terms of me saying i'm nervous about
obviously discriminating so by putting
something in mandatory i always have to
say what what is the sort of causal
effect there because if we put something
in that immediately prevents smes vcscs
as smaller entities from bidding then i
might have improved a target here but i
haven't started to reduce a target over
here so for me it's just being very
clear and careful about when we start to
bring things into the procurement
process that we're not adversely
upsetting not upsetting but actually
having an impact on another target
that's important to us so i will say
it's a very early stage of talking about
carbon um and i will be working with
with experts here um across the four
councils to make sure we get this as
right as it can be
thank you chad and thank you lorraine um
first time i've had a presentation on
star so that's really interesting i
guess my questions are around
um
scale and benchmarking
so you said oh made up of these
constituent parts
is that a large scale relative to other
local authority and public sector
procurement bodies
and is there potential for growth in
star that was question one
on the benchmarking side you had some
absolute numbers in there so 6.1 million
pounds i think you said um
saved how do we know
that that's a good result is there any
way of benchmarking versus other
procurement groups to see whether 6.1 is
best in class thank you
okay thank you for those two questions
the first one is around growth um
when staff formed eight years ago
i think all ten councils put their hand
in the air i'm told and said yes we'd
all love to be a shared service and as
you know as conversations develop um
people start to look at the pros and the
cons of joining a shared service and we
ended up with three and i think thanks
to trafford at the time who were quite
brave and eight years ago was a long
time ago in terms of shared services
being established um
they took the lead they offered to host
the organization um and i will say it's
now being recognized nationally as a
success story and i won't name names but
i am meeting with three councils down
south next week who want to form their
own star
um so they're actually using the model
of operation that we've got up here and
they're actually saying can we actually
buy in some consultancy because we'd
like to create our own entity that
copies and mirrors the star model and in
terms of regional growth which i think
is is more the point that you're
actually asking me here um
i do have interest from a couple of
other councils i can't obviously name
the name um at the moment because we're
just in early discussions and we are
undertaking some commissions for those
particular authorities at the moment in
terms of putting some capacity in
putting some learning in advising them
on social value so i'm optimistic that
hopefully in the future um others will
actually take a serious consideration of
joining staff from within the region um
equally we're doing some work over in
the merseyside region at the moment um
and there is um three possibly four
councils over there that are actually
thinking of coming together to form a
procurement collaboration and one of
their considerations is you know do they
join star do they actually create their
own and so part of their sort of options
appraisal will be to explore all of that
so i think growth is absolutely very
much on the agenda um but i think what
tends to happen is you talk you start to
see a pattern of where an organization
is perhaps failing in procurement due to
staff turnover um or maybe they've
obviously got budget pressures and they
think well we'd quite like six million
you know how do we how do we get that
um to answer your second question um
counsellor in terms of the 6.1 million
um what we can provide is the history of
what we've delivered every year for the
last eight years because i think that
will show you that there's a there's a
consistency and that target is also
increased annually by star joint
committee this year was the only year
they didn't increase it because they
just gave me a reprieve on the fact that
obviously we've been going through the
pandemic and those other pressures and
and to make sure that we're putting our
efforts and support into businesses to
making sure they were able to deliver
contracts and able to deliver social
value but there is definitely a
consistency in terms of our um delivery
um the fact we deliver on average four
times return for every pound that you
spend nationally is benchmarked against
other organizations and that is classed
as best in class
okay
thompson
thank you for your presentation i just
want to go back to the social value
performance and and trafford's huge
increase to 67
and you mentioned that was based on the
sale of
sale magistrates courts for the
development of buildings and
houses and social housing
so my question is
is the social value on projected social
value because that's not actually say a
magistrate's court hasn't happened
there's no guarantee it's going to
happen so is it like a projected kind of
thing rather than based on what's
actually happened that's a really good
point we we capture it and report on it
on the basis of what comes through the
offer when the person or the contractor
is bidding and then the winning bidder
will actually put that offer and that
will become contractual and so when the
contract commences they are
contractually committed to deliver that
social value back to us so that's that's
for all contracts not not just sale
magistrates but any contract at all but
we also use the social value portal
which is why the portal is important to
us to actually contract manage to ensure
that points mean prizes people are
winning contracts and actually they are
actually delivering on what they've
promised one of the biggest criticisms i
think nationally and still nationally
for the public sector is that people are
winning contracts with social value um
in the evaluation but actually do they
ever actually deliver it and and i think
where was i recently um
it might have been a meeting with the
leader actually with one of the unions
that was one of the challenges they put
was was actually are they actually
delivering this because why it's amazing
saying oh look you've secured 30 million
a year across the four councils but do
we ever see it does it ever happen and
one thing i can say is we have a
contract management tool and we have
contract managers within my team as well
as the contract managers that do your
performance management within
departments um to ensure that that
actual 30 million as it is per year that
we've secured in the last two years is
actually delivered because ultimately
it's fraudulent because they would be
winning contracts without actually
giving us what their points have scored
them for so it's very audible it's um
very transparent and there is a
contractual relationship with the
contractor to ensure that that is
delivered
thank you for coming it's a really very
informative
uh
my question regarding spend and
compliance outputs
uh
i mean
controllable spend 39 percent
how we do we prefer spending more are we
spending preferences saving more
because in in economy yes if you spend
more yes it is better yes and so this is
my very simple question yeah it's a good
point um i think that the ambition isn't
your grain wouldn't want us to spend
more because he's obviously got to
balance the accounts for the council
so so yeah it's a very valid point for
me it's about spending it on the right
things and making sure we get the right
value so if we're buying tarmac
you know do we need the goals tarmac or
do are we happy with the bronze tarmac
and it's about making sure we're
balancing that value for money piece and
that's what procurement does very very
well is it's not we used to just you
know have everything didn't we in the
good old days of the public sector and
now we know we can't afford it we
shouldn't have it and we've got to
rationalize and we've got to shop around
and that's what procurement does for you
as it shops around it negotiates it also
works in collaboration so we're a bigger
buyer so we have a bigger influence on
the market to get you the best deal so
we want to spend all of your money but
equally we want to get you the most bang
for your buck i suppose it means we
we prefer to spend money on productive
measures where we can create more
revenue and employment
yes and what social value does is it
brings that pound that then can be
recycled so the more the more pounds of
more of traffic's pounds i can get spent
in trafford that pound gets spent
because the contractors eat drink sleep
go to the schools in trafford
and obviously they've got the
communities um within trafford so that
pound is is recycled over and over
that's why i need trafford's pounds in
trafford not in london well that's it
very quickly yes uh can you please more
elaborate a little uh social what it
covers social values it covers a little
bit more words yeah i want to listen
three three areas social environmental
and um
economic i couldn't remember the third
important economic very important yeah
this is the new job absolutely so so for
me by getting contracts um delivered
locally means we're boosting the the
local economy because we're spending
that pound the example i've just given
if you look at environmental issues it
may be that we challenge the contractors
in a different way and we could say well
actually what about your carbon
emissions and what what are you going to
put in we used to talk about um recycled
ink cartridges i think that was the only
thing we could think about you know
probably not many years ago but it's
actually to say what are you doing to be
planet conscious and traffic conscious
and actually looking global and local to
bring environmental gains it may be that
they say well we're going to look at
deliveries and we're going to say
actually we normally go into traffic
three times a week to deliver xyz we're
going to do it once and we're actually
going to buy a bigger van hopefully a
green van and actually we're going to do
yours and we're going to do the neighbor
borough so we challenge the contract to
think differently and offer social value
it's a blank sheet we don't tell them
what we they have to do we very much
like them to come and tell us what they
want to do
in terms of social gain that's more
around actually helping people in the
community it might be education it might
be homelessness it may be that um you
want us to work with with armed forces
and get you know
ex-veterans back into employment it may
be maybe a homelessness campaign um it
may be that you just actually want um
better value places for residential care
so the social gain can come in lots of
different ways but mark if you could
maybe circulate the tom's measures again
because i know there's a couple of new
councillors in the room and then what i
will also do is once we get the
shortlist of toms for trafford i'll send
those to mark and get those circulated
as well so you can start to see how they
link to your new corporate priorities as
well so you can see what we're targeting
in in that sort of menu i think that
would be helpful thank you
okay
again
thanks chair um i'd imagine procurement
is all about creating a document where
you really nail down the requirements of
what you want to the
very specific detail
um
how do you kind of check that they're
meeting those requirements and
have you ever had to
kind of stop a contract
procurement is is very much around the
specification um
traditionally it's been very much about
the specification where we explicitly
say we need you to do xyz you know by a
timeline or with a certain performance
indicator and how that is traditionally
contract managers done by the
commissioning team within the council
who have a responsibility to contract
manage so that doesn't actually sit with
star procurement other than the social
value element so that's where the sort
of checks and balances come from within
but what we're doing now is we're moving
to a way where we start to build more of
a partnership and co-creation approach
where we will actually meet with
potential bidders and we talk to bidders
and so what we do is we look at their
innovation we look at their creation we
look at perhaps ways that they've worked
in other authorities or with other
organizations regionally and what that
really really does is it gives the
experts actually to help the council
officers to actually think about
something differently and better because
at the end of the day a lot of the
organizations we work with do have
social conscience and social ambition as
an organization particularly voluntary
community sector particularly smes who
are perhaps you know very intimate in
terms of being within the borough of
trafford and they probably know the
borough better than i certainly do as a
procurement lead so it's very important
that we take a balanced approach of
co-creation
and actually look at that innovation
with the market and and not just say
well there's the spec and you must tell
it you must deliver to what we need and
i think for me we do this on smaller
contracts but we also do it on something
called competitive dialogue with your
very big multi-million pound contracts
where we actually do negotiation um i
could get really technical here but we
do negotiation on the journey of
procurement because then it gives the
contractor
an influence in a safe
auditable environment to actually offer
something different so we squeeze and
squeeze and squeeze and work with them
so we get the very best deal at the end
so it's not just about specifying we we
do have that sort of open dialogue as
well
okay any further questions
counselor
thank you last question very quickly
when we are talking about procurement
and
do we obviously we we are interested to
create more and more job opportunities
as well am i right okay so do we
consider or do we have any any yardstick
to make sure there is an equal
opportunities
for job opportunities for everyone
this is the part of the
uh your agenda as well it is very much
part of my gender what we're working on
at the moment is to understand the
priorities and needs and the baseline of
that information within trafford because
what i need to understand is you may
have a particular just say a particular
award in trafford that might be
extremely deprived that has a high
unemployment rate and what we can
eventually do is say to the contractor
you must deliver
the job opportunities to that particular
award we can actually go down to ward
level if we want to do that and that
will be from what what you tell us what
your core priorities tell us what your
data people tell us and that's what my
ambition is for the next 12 months to
flip it on its head so you get what you
need for the right people rather than a
contract you're just saying yeah we'll
just play the game and we'll bring 20
new people in but we'll decide where
they come from and who they are so it's
very much flipping it so it's outcome
driven rather than the business just
offering us what they want to give us
thank you
thank you this is plant did you want i'm
sorry if i missed you there
hillary um what it was laureen it was
just on your slide you know the one
that's got all the the figures on could
i just clarify um
the controllable spend that was in the
turquoise is the middle bit
supposed to add up to the controllable
spend or is there something else that's
missing you know in between the two i
just wondered
if i was misinterpreting it at all
no all you've got no no the top line is
the total spencer traffic six to 26
million the controllable spend is the
extract
so we take that one away from the other
the rest of it
bits i can't is
so if you just take the small figure
away from the big figure what's left is
what basically runs through your account
in terms of it'll have bitcoin capacity
stepping um
so i probably could have put the
balancing figure on but i haven't done
okay sorry i might not have made myself
clear um the bit that's in the middle
the 97 and the 78
and the 65 yes yes
spent nationally and contained with gm
that section
is that supposed to um
agree to the 244
yeah so
no no i just wanted to clarify because i
in case i misunderstood so i think maybe
just
double check the 20 21 and 1920. there
just might be a bit around it so i
thought maybe something had been taken
out
possibly
thank you thank you
yeah i think the 1819 but like i said
maybe there's just something else that's
changed over the last couple of years
okay no no thanks i just
thank you
when i was at work i used to
blame rounding errors for things like
that
yeah because
his boys
i think that's exactly what you've got
to share because i mean basically they
don't add up to the pound
but it will be rounding iris i mean i
think that's exactly that explanation
oh i'm glad i got away with this again i
i didn't add them all up but if if
they're within a pound obviously it's
rounding errors
so any more questions i'll be finished
there
thanks thanks very much thanks very much
lorraine your enthusiasm shines through
as always when you come to talk about
these things
just
yeah that's true enough
just follow on for the questions raised
by councillor thompson and uh councilman
jerome i think next time you come if we
come next year perhaps it would be
interesting to know just what has
happened to some of these contracts you
know did they what were they supposed to
deliver and did they deliver them
i know you can't perhaps mention what
the contracts are but if we just have
some idea
exactly that that would be i think
helpful stuff
[Laughter]
reporting love
so you can actually see how that links
to corporate priorities and how i'm
switching the the
the way my team loves me they just say
well where are she going now with this
one but what we're trying to do is
switch it so it's outcomes driven now
we've got a model that works rather than
yeah thanks for that because i think as
an audit committee we're obviously
interested in did people deliver what
they said they were going to deliver
yeah yeah
okay well thanks hope your traffic's
cleared by the time you're going home
should we've been by now yeah
well thanks once again thank you
all right uh colleagues now on to item
six the external auditor's annual report
which they came separately remember um
and karen presume you're going to
i will do thank you chair
so the audience's annual report is a new
um report slightly different if you're
liking content and format than reports
you've received from us in the past
although much of the purpose is the same
so the idea
behind this report is quite similar to
what the old annual audit letter used to
do which is to provide you with a final
summary of all the work that we've done
for the year
and to be publicly available so that
people who are interested in what the
auditor thinks about the arrangements in
trafford
is it you know those people are able to
access it and find out what we think
this does two things for you it
summarizes um the work that we did on
your financial statements to give the
audit opinion and you will recall that i
presented a rather long report on the
outcome of that work in the at the
november meeting so this report just
provides a very summarized position
um it highlights the fact that we came
to your november meeting um and then
repeats the key messages which are the
really important bits for people to
understand which is that we gave an
unqualified opinion on the accounts and
those accounts were good in terms of the
quality of what was submitted for audit
the second thing that this report then
does is talks about your arrangements
for securing value for money
this is the new bit if you like and the
reason why the report's got a slightly
different title than it's had before
members will be aware
that the national audit office code in
respect of um value for money work that
auditors were required to do
changed for this year so this is the
first year that we've reported under
this this this
model
um we are asked to consider whether the
council has proper arrangements in place
for delivering value for money across
three criteria so the first is your
financial sustainability so whether or
not the council has proper arrangements
for planning and managing resources so
that it can continue to deliver services
for people in trafford
secondly around the council's
arrangements for governance that is how
you take decisions and ensure they're
properly informed
and how you manage your risks
and then thirdly in terms of improving
economy efficiency and effectiveness so
that's what you're doing to use
cost and performance information to
improve services for residents and
visitors to the borough of trafford
the way that this process works is that
we identify any potential risks and then
do works form of you as to whether or
not those risks are real
significant weaknesses in your
arrangements and we provide a commentary
on each area
you will see that we did identify
significant weakness in the arrangements
in trafford and that's in respect to
children's services following the offset
inspection
offset assessed the council services
inadequate and
our conclusion is that it still
represents a significant weakness in
your overall arrangements around
governance and performance
this report sets out and and the reason
that this is an improvement if you like
on the old value for money work that we
used to do is it gives us much more
opportunity to flash out what the
council's doing and how the council is
responding
so the report sets out the actions that
have been taken it acknowledges the fact
that the improvement board has been set
up that you identified financial
resources in order to support the action
plan that you need to put in place for
children's services it comments on the
fact that there is an action plan that
you've had changes in leadership and so
on but unfortunately there is still no
evidence um particularly from the
follow-up work that offset have done
that sufficient progress has been made
to remove that
their concern around your your overall
rating
the other thing that i just want to say
in this report really and i'm not going
to go through it on a page by page basis
but is just to recognize that your
financial sustainability
and our judgment on that is finally
balanced
so i don't want anyone to read this
report and think everything's all right
in financial front because i think your
director of finance will probably um not
agree with that you do have some real
challenges that you need to address so
you are facing increased demand for your
services you have got the same pressures
on your financial position that most of
the rest of the world understand at the
moment around inflation particularly
pay inflation and the cost of energy and
so on but there are other things
you've unfortunately had another
one-year settlement from central
government which makes longer-term
planning very difficult
you've got the cost of covered recovery
to it to address going forwards whether
that's because you're providing new
services or because your income is down
because of corvid or or whatever those
those things may be
and the gap you have in your financial
plan or had at the start of the
financial plan was very large
now you do have plans in place to close
that gap you do have a very good track
record of delivering plans when you
identify them and set them up
but i don't want you to underestimate
the challenge
i don't want you to get the impression
from me that your financial
sustainability is fine because the one
thing you have done over the last few
years is rely on reserves to help you to
smooth the path to to make things um
happen over time and you are not going
to be able to continue to do that in the
medium term
you need to be absolutely clear as a
committee and hold the rest of the
council to account for this that where
there are plans in place that need
reserves to
act as an investor save strategy that
you really are delivering on that so the
arrangements that you put in place to
modernize how to
to monitor how the savings are coming
through from the modernization activity
that you're planning to undertake will
be really important and we may end up
having a very different conversation in
a couple of years time if those savings
are not coming through on the scale and
at the pace you need them to because
your reserves simply will not carry on
funding services for that
period
so i'm going to stop talking there
because i think probably i've done the
kind of two big messages but i'm happy
to take any questions if there are any
either on the report or about any of the
things that i've said
thanks karen any questions members
no well
it goes very well thank you
always ask a question
when you talk about the invest to to
save strategy i kind of referring to the
we had a new invest in children's
services
some years ago when i first started and
it hasn't come to fruition for whatever
reason covered and and financial reasons
is is that the kind of thing you you're
talking about
it is yeah there are some things where
it is it is
probably inevitable that you will need
to put some money in in order to get
savings out in the future so the best
example of that is anything that you
decide you want to do that increases the
amount of digitalization or automation
in the way that the cable does things as
soon as you start to go down that road
in a particular service area or whatever
almost certainly you've got to pay for
the software the training the
development and and the change in the
way that you operate but in the longer
term in two years time or whatever that
will deliver benefits by needing fewer
staff or a different working model or
whatever so when we talk about investors
that's what we mean
i went to a great demonstration by
southampton city council who were using
ai to
deliver all their kind of telephony um
these days which which is amazing and
saving them money
is it more complicated in that we've got
a private contractor
um
dealing with our services which would
make it
extra difficult to modernize and change
potentially in the extent to services
we've got delivered under the
from the council um
part of the budget papers and the
strategy around how we're going to
deliver savings there is quite a big
emphasis around digital strategy
robotics and what we can do internally
um
i think the work we're doing with amy as
well
um
and how we're looking to
move that contract forward is to seek
improvements and obviously those
improvements have got to be
i've have in the back of the mind
sustainability and sustainability
improvements as well that can be
generated from digital so i think it
will cover the piece of what we do
okay any other questions got the light
um how
i know this may be a difficult question
but it's that offset that the um you
know
the money's been put in
it doesn't appear to be liberating how
how
long can ofsted be around really because
it's been three years now and i know
there's been a pandemic
but
also social
social services do suffer from um i
think they've had to use temporary staff
and things like this
um to be able to deliver some services
okay so
um
i suppose the really short answer to
that is ofsted will be around for as
long as they need to be
so they will keep coming back until
they're satisfied with the quality of
the service that the council is
providing for children and that's that's
right that that's their role that's the
right thing for them to do
i think it's really unfortunate that
you're off your first offstead
inspection in 2019 you put an action
plan in place yeah you were doing all
the right things and if i'm being really
honest i think you got a bit blown by
corvid because all of a sudden you were
dealing with a very different problem
and although you've continued to make
improvements and i've said have
commented on the fact that some aspects
are improving what we've not seen yet is
that that's embedded and it's going to
be sustainable going forwards for
exactly the reasons that you just said
because social care social workers um
one of those areas where there's a
massive amount of demand for people so
even when you get the right workforce
and you you reduce your urgency somebody
else needs more social workers
the rate of pay goes up people move on
it's real it's a real challenging area
because there are just a shortage of
appropriate people
so it will continue to be a you know a
service you need to work with but as i
say
the last monitoring visit they did
comment on the change that they could
see
um and their last their latest concern
was more about the sustainability of
that for longer term
okay council carter
[Music]
thanks chair um
you made reference to
much publicized pressures particularly
coming from
wage increases inflation um etc how well
do you assess that trafford council are
doing in
realistically anticipating what and
forecasting what they're likely to be
and building that into the
forecasts
so i think in common with a number of
authorities you have very good
arrangements in place for making
assumptions you don't you don't make
outlandish assumptions shall i say they
are reasonable they're sadly based and
actually if i look across
the sector as a whole a lot of the
assumptions are very similar
um
you are
lucky i think
although graham will probably tell me
it's called planning that um lots of the
assumptions that you made around the
income streams have either
been favorable you've got more in than
you expected or they've held true so
there aren't any areas where you
actually got significantly less money in
than you anticipated
but and and here is the challenge isn't
it i don't think any
financial plan anywhere anticipated that
energy costs would rise in the way that
we now think they will and the impact on
that for individual parts of service for
schools for example will be significant
and you will need to find ways to close
that gap now there will be things you
can do around how and when you procure
um and how long a time period and so on
but that's a that's a new and emerging
pressure i was talking to an
organization the other day here was
talking horrific numbers in terms of the
pressure he was going to put on their
budget so while she had an allowance in
your plans for
inflation and it was higher on energy i
suspect the actual the actual outcome
will be worse so so you make the right
assumptions based on the best knowledge
you've got
yeah i think that was the um the number
of my question not how well did we
anticipate 12 months ago something that
was completely unpredictable but given
us the years unfolding how well are we
as a council responding and
realistically realistically reflecting
the new truth that inflation's five
percent plus
and energy prices are anything from 50
to 50 plus
it's not precise science and all that i
think what we've done
we do regularly refresh we've upped our
budget assumptions again and it's not
there's obviously concerns we've got
around pay these concerns about general
inflation
energy inflation
concerns about inflation on national
living wages real living wages that
affect the care market so we've got a
whole raft of council services affected
by
the the range of inflationary increases
we've got
we've made assumptions for next year
to give those specific budget areas
increases for those we have also built
in quite significant contingencies as
well within our plans as well
um
obvious budget next year will be about
190 million net and so obviously we need
to maintain them contingencies but
potentially we're going to have call as
a result of inflation next year as well
okay
i think that's it uh karen thanks very
much for that thank you not all good
news but not not uh
like the uh
parsons egg where it was good in parts
yeah
can we move on then to uh item seven
treasury management annual strategy
report graham are you taking those times
yes i'll tell this thank you chair um
just to put this report into context and
i think just the next couple of weeks
into context really
we've got budget council coming up on
the 16th of february
there's a suite of budget reports
of which the treasury management report
is obviously a key component of them
it is an important report
purely because of
it holds a lot of budgets together and
it links to a lot of budget so it links
to the revenue budget in terms of the
interest cost that we get the investment
interest it links to the capital
programme because we take out debt to
finance some of our capital expenditure
so it's quite an integral report to the
suite of budget reports we do
um
in terms of accounts and audit
committee's role
i think what we do is we always bring
this report to this committee before it
goes to the executive and then before it
goes to council for formal approval of
the different limits and strategies
within it
um obviously as you know it's highly
regulated i think you've probably heard
that at previous meetings there's a lot
of codes from our professional bodies
from government
around um the treasury strategies that
we've got and just to put it into
context when you think at the moment the
figures in the report as of december
um provide the information that the
council's got in the region of 50
million pounds worth of debt and about
130 million pounds of investment so it's
quite significant in terms of
um
the controls we need around our treasury
function and and do have around our
treasury function um
i will skip through some of the key
sections in the report not in great
detail
there was um
and i hope you found it useful last week
this session that was provided by
our our team and uh link group who are
our treasury advisors but just in terms
of the report the brief
for the report the key sections is
around
borrowings which is included within
section four and it's probably just
worth noting we only borrow for capital
expenditure so we borrow to support the
expenditure in the capital programme
that covers things like school building
highway works the asset strategy so
those are the real things that we borrow
for and we only borrow if we know
it's prudent and affordable to do so so
if we've got the income stream to pay
that borrowing back we will do that
um
and obviously that borrowing that
we undertake is approved by council so
they set limits as to what we will
borrow and that's agreed by council
um section five mrp strategy
basically
that strategy is just the way we plan to
save up to repay our debt
um
and again a lot of regulations
and i think
the authority complies with all the
regulations to repay debt um
the only area that we don't comply with
and we continue not to comply with is
where we borrow money
to lend to third parties where we have
total comfort that monies will get
repaid so the quite short term so part
of our asset investment strategy that we
deliver through the capital program and
not to be confused with treasury
management but
where we lend through that strategy
and we've got agreement that is
short-term lending and we know we're
going to get the money back we don't set
aside minimum revenue provision from our
revenue budget because we know we're
going to get repaid the funds
now
i would just add to that that
what government's looking at and they
have looked at over the last two or
three years is try to
tighten all the rules around local
authority activity particularly around
asset investment strategies and they are
looking at this aspect of mrp i must say
i've attended a workshop on monday
because government's consulting on this
change
and there wasn't a treasurer there who
was supportive of it and i think
where the authority is lending money
with the assurance that that money is
going to come back
then
i'm i'm of the opinion that to set aside
money through revenue again would be
double providing for that debt but we'll
wait and see we'll react to whatever
comes out of that consultation but
that's not effective until april 23.
um
just in terms of
this the scale of mrp we pay set aside
about eight million pounds a year
towards our debt repayments so that
accumulates such that when debt matures
we've got enough money in the bank to
repay it
just on the investment side of things
sorry
it will yeah repaid
there are a lot of uh
councils
in this uh
nation that knew that the
icelandic banks would pay
[Music]
there's never 100 certainty but what i'm
talking about here is where we've lent
money and we've got to charge on an
asset
so
we've
we've got senior debt
lent against somebody's assets where
we know the value of those assets will
be significantly higher than the level
of debt we've went so we do have quite a
fair degree of certainty around that
lending
so just just in terms of the investment
strategy within the report
the key principle around the investing
and the invested of the surplus cash
we've got
revolves around the term
security liquidity yield
so
we invest the council's cash daily
through the treasury function
um
basically to work the spare cash that
we've got at any point in time and to
make sure that cash is available when we
need it
what the strategy details is
who do we invest with
and we invest with what we call
counterparties so it's mainly banks
building societies money market funds
strong credit rated institutions
and what we set is limits in terms of
how much we can invest with certain
counterparties and what duration we can
invest that money in
what we also look at is
default risk
that's a consideration we've got to make
and these are the things that we will
regularly monitor as we're investing
that portfolio of cash on a regular
basis
um just in terms of other aspects of the
report there's a section on prudential
indicators which give basically
indicators around
overall debt levels that the authority
should be working within
and like i said they support some of the
proposals within our capital programme
again which are agreed at council so
um i think that's
the overview i'd like to give and i'm
obviously happy to take any questions
thanks graeme any questions
graham has given a very comprehensive
answer to my colleague
we can't give any
prediction about the future of the
finance because
future about economy is always
speculative
so you can't give 100 guarantee so i'm
agree with you
thank you
i think um
i totally agree i've i've worked with
local government finance about 32 years
and every year that uncertainty and as
karen said earlier one year financial
settlements we're working from one year
to the next but trying to set
medium-term budgets
and it's yeah it's volatile quite
difficult
comes to carter
i just to thank you for the report just
to go back to um the previous previous
question the two biggest numbers in
appendix 7 around regeneration
investments are cis manchester and hut
group hq
are both of those cases of what you
described where we have a
hold on the assets
and therefore aren't
exposed to
kind of market trading risk that was the
60 ml on cis and the 67.5 on hot group
in respect to the cis
yes and that's an investment that we've
got placed
um but it's it's a charge on the
property in respect to the hawk group
that's a commitment so
the money still sat in the council's
bank account we've not went it yet
okay so if it will and if it's where
we'll be
on the assets thank you very much
thanks for council jerome
[Music]
um i'm just wondering that um
interest rates have been
low it's been unprecedented you know
that they've been
almost at zero for
since 20
2008 onwards really
um which has probably never happened in
economic history which has probably
given the councils and other councils
some certainty but now it looks as
though they'll be rising to
you know stop inflation um
is that going to be difficult for the
council to manage
i think
there's a couple of aspects to to think
about there it's
in investment terms rising interest
rates is
good it's better return
in borrowing terms and they can be
slightly different markets what would
the rise in the base rate
automatically give rise to an increase
in borrowing costs
not necessarily
i think when we look at the the
borrowings of the council they are
fixed-rate debt
um so it won't affect historic debt the
extent it affects future debt is
something we'll have to have a look at
but we have got
um projections of where some of those
interest rates will go and when we're
looking at business cases around new
investment we tend to consider on the
high side which reflects these
forecasted interest rates for debt
so it's a combination of things real
this is platform
hi graeme um very very minor just for
clarification on appendix um six
there's interest for aspirational
strategic investment growth it's a bit
of a mouthful um it's in twice is it
just
a typo
the first line of that is when i've
printed the reports off to look for
budget council we've removed that line
it's done to affect the subtotal it's
just in twice
thank you
councilor boys
yeah thank you earth and thank you for
your report just i'm just trying to get
my head around one thing that you said
and whether it's part of what you
already said about or what and that was
when you're talking about
examples of us borrowing
to thence lend albeit confidently but i
think you use sort of like short term so
the examples of us doing that
would be
what in the past or currently
forgot my microphone again um
off through the asset investment
strategy and an example would be
um lending to
we did some investment with
um
this escape at castle urwell to develop
residential property
so this was a short term what they call
short-term senior debt facility
to support the development of that
regeneration scheme
so that involves yeah it's just a
short-term
third-party loan
well
thank you any
other questions
no
no external orders want to ask anything
oh no no
thanks okay thanks very much uh graeme
for that can we move on to item eight
the budget monitoring period eight again
this is hugh graham
yeah i'll tell this one as well um
yeah this is the regular budget
monitoring report that went to executive
earlier in uh back in january
um sets the position on
where we think our budget and projected
spends going to end up at the end of the
year
um you you'll recall from
previous monitoring reports that that
position
hadn't looked that great we've been
reporting at period four and six about
two and a half million pound projected
all the spend
i think
what we've seen this time is positively
a favorable movement on that position so
it's improved by about a million pounds
um
a few things have contributed to that
and i think just a couple of notable
ones just to bring to the committee's
attention is just
what we've had through this year is
a hospital discharge program to include
uh to improve on discharges from
hospital
um governments supported us in doing
that through something called the
hospital discharge fund
so in effect they've contributed to some
of our costs
now
what we keep getting from government is
a widening of that scheme and what we
can claim for so we see the benefits of
that through the monitor we can't
predict it because we don't know what
government's going to do so that's
brought in more income
we've also had elements of management
action that we initiated in previous
budget monitors to try and bring the
physician back
and a combination of those two is the
reason why obviously we've seen this
positive movement
um
since last period uh period six i think
what we're still seeing we're still
projecting an overspender 1.4 i think
what we do have still in our budget
plans are one or two contingency pockets
so we've still got contingencies in some
of the demand led services which
if that demand doesn't materialize we
don't use so they get fed back and they
benefit that position i think the other
thing to just note is that
one of the concerns we had when when we
set the budget we didn't budget for a
pay award for staff on the basis of the
the comments about our public sector pay
freeze
um
the unions were balloting last month for
a potential industrial action on the
basis of their claims
for pay rises
that um
ballot's been unsuccessful i think it
was quite a low turnout
so we won't get
uh strike action and we think that that
1.75 percent at the moment probably
around where we'll end up settling so
in terms of
staff not good news but in terms of
budget
uh it gives us that predictability in
terms of where our budget position may
end up
um so some quite positive news on that i
think what we've also seen
this this month is
an improved position on our council tax
collection and business rates collection
and i think what we're going to do with
that benefit at the moment is we're
aiming to put that into reserves again
just so we can support our budget
resilience and the position that karen's
outlined um going forward so
um
i don't want to say any more you've got
the report but i'm happy to take any
questions chair
answer many questions
councillor thompson
[Music]
thank you graeme i wonder if you could
update us on um what might be happening
with the manchester airport group and
the funding that we might get from them
going forwards
thanks
yeah it's good question i think
obviously
prior to covid um
trafford along with all the other nine
gm districts has got a shareholding
manchester's i think
we've got about three percent
shareholding i think manchester's
36
there's another partner that's got an
equivalent shareholding and the other
nine districts have got about three
percent we were receiving dividends
until corvid in the region of about five
and a half million
um
they've disappeared
um
the indications are
from the airport that
in the medium term we're not to
predict any
i think at the moment
the last thing we heard obviously
things were
improving but then omicron struck
so they took a a bit of a dive
um and hopefully
it will take off again
for want of a pun
but
what the council does have as well
and again similar to all districts all
districts are pretty much aligned
obviously manchester's
ten times more
aligned than using the the size of the
shareholding but we do give all the
shareholder loans as well to the airport
for example when they've had
improvements to some of the terminals in
previous years
each of the gm districts have given
loans
at the moment
the payments of the interest
are not being made
um
so in cash terms we're not getting paid
the interest on those loans but the
interest is being accrued
so
when things do return
from the airport the first thing they
will do is honor the obligations they've
got around some of those debt
arrangements
but unfortunately what that does is it
pushes back any dividend payment
so
it's difficult to project but in our
medium term plans we've not got an
assumption on airport dividend which is
a quite a challenge considering how much
it was
because the boys yeah on that one yeah i
mean the the covered effect there was a
lot of money
actually because a covid loan to the
airport that will
have to be paid back first
before
there's any thought of any dividends i
mean
i'm struggling to think it would be in
my lifetime actually the amount of money
that had to be pumped into the airport
so it didn't go bust
back whatever two years ago i mean what
we were talking 250 million quid or
something it was leaking cash at the
rate of 25 25 million pounds a month
so i mean it's sort of
yeah
very unlikely you're going to get
dividends for the very for well the
foreseeable future just quite a term
foreseeable i think
just to respond to that the loans were
long term so
it's like like the other shareholder
loans are quite long term
but it's the interest payments that will
be they will be repaid
first
but like let's say the cash will on the
go so far and that's their priority
we do account for the income from the
shareholder loans but it's just a cash
flow timing issue that
this is more of a comment than a
question really um i suppose from a
budgetary point of view a pay rise for
staff is
probably looked on as a difficult thing
to manage but it's actually probably the
right thing to do so if anybody is
watching
the youtube
you know
you know the pay rise is actually a good
thing as well as being a difficult thing
to manage financially
okay yeah council lie to say
um it's just those um red
and appendix to the ones that you've
highlighted in red where the
savings are not going to
um
be managed really
um some of it's unpredictable and some
of it's um
like the fact the legislation is coming
in next year
uh to the
liberty one
um but
there's a lot there
that isn't being saved and given what
you've been saying how can we meet
against admit again
mitigate against that
and because if we don't achieve savings
then we're going to have to depend on
reserves
in some
in some respects
i think it's a really good question i
think that's the difficulty in terms of
where local government is we've we've
delivered savings programs for
the last 11 12 years
inevitably
they get more difficult um
i think this position has been one of
our more challenging ones and i think
what we've got to be mindful of when
we're setting budgets is
don't just impact this year it's
obviously a contributing factor to the
in-year budget position but what does it
mean for next year these were savings
that we're not achieving this year
some of these have not forwarded we'll
get we'll have a delivery potential for
next year so those have been considered
within our budget planning going forward
some warned
and that's the challenge we've got to
identify new sustainable savings to
bridge that medium-term gap
but i think it's a challenge for
everybody we've heard um obviously on
the press recently what uh we're always
doing
um i don't think there's any council in
the country not
um
scratching the heads around what to do
around sustainability
but and it's not held by the fact that
three-year budget one-year settlement
it's
um
silly really but it just makes our our
planning really difficult but we just do
know best projections and the scenario
planning we do do is going to be really
difficult but will involve the need to
make more and more recurrent savings
i suppose in
budget terms in the context of the
budget
about
190 million will be the net budget next
year
what does that budget grow by year on
year so when you think about pay rises
inflation demographic pressures you're
probably talking between eight and ten
million pound of
growth in costs just to deliver what you
delivered this year
as an example council tax offsets that
but the government obviously restrict
what you can increase council tax by
um
limits next year i think are
2.99
so for authority like trafford's that's
3 billion so you've already got a
standstill position if
you've got a net figure to find there of
about
five million pound
in the region just to stand still
um
but the compounding issue is the more
reserves you use in a year to balance
budget that's saying i've not met the
savings target i've used reserves
temporarily you've still got that saving
to find so that can compound the issues
that
trafford and other authorities will face
going forward
okay thank you any more questions guess
what jerome again
um just a quick question from my
understanding really so you are you
saying that you might have the reserve
one year which you've spent to help your
budget but the next year you might not
have that reserve and then you have to
find the money elsewhere
correct yeah was it once used once and
gone
yeah
okay thank you graeme i'm going to item
uh nine audition insurance report
markets useless thank you chair
uh this is a further update on on audit
work completed um a fairly brief time
period just from november up to
christmas
um
obviously continuing to progress
the internal audit plan
um in terms of outcomes for the period
um
that well there's a table on page 93
that summarizes reviews
um there were four
final reports issued
um a couple of those one around social
value uh where we
worked with lorraine's service just
following up on previous recommendations
around social value and that so related
to the systems that got in place around
the social value portal and showing that
good progress have been made and
implementing and i think the report
talks about some in progress and they've
actually been pretty well completed now
um there's also a school audit in there
which which we've provided a reasonable
level of assurance
um a couple of other audits where we
didn't provide a formal audit opinion um
because we recognized there was a lot of
activity currently going on and we
wanted to sort of assess that
when further work had been done one
example around business continuity where
there's a lot of activity in terms of um
developing plans at the moment so we
will be including those the audit
planner will come to the committee's
next meeting and we're going to be
including both that and supporting
families areas uh within the next audit
plan
there's also you see a number of reports
in a draft stage which will also report
to part of the quarter four updates so
it was a
process around highways inspection
repairs maybe
and also an i.t asset management review
how how are we managing all our devices
laptops phones and everything else it's
a
properly controlled
uh environment
um
just then moving on to uh the next
section page 94 just to summarize all
the work we've been doing
and particularly just to point out the
section now on the national fraud
initiative um we've just provided a very
brief update on on outcomes to date so
there was a whole host of of data
submitted to the cabinet office which
your councils across the country had to
do
and then a
data matching exercise takes place where
trafford receives a list of data matches
from the the uh the data we submitted so
audit had a role in coordinating that
submitting the data
um so the outcomes from that to now
probably more relevant in terms of the
counter fraud team which will
update you um later in the year um but a
small number of errors
uh highlighted from the matches done
with particular ones around covert 19
small business grants i think work is in
progress at the moment around that but
there were certainly three
uh examples where they found that the
grants were paid incorrectly
and i know they're following that up in
terms of recovery uh
the amounts i think david wright with
his counter fraud update um i'm sure
quick will elaborate
um down the line on on that work
um
just then moving on in terms of of
during the period the impact of audit
work we've continued to get positive
response to our our recommendations
uh with with most new audit
recommendations being accepted
um
terms of follow-up work um again good
progress being made uh some areas where
we've noted work
is in progress in it in progressing
recommendations and where that's the
case we'll be including any any of those
within within next year's um audit plan
i mean the example of business
continuity there where we know it was
quite a few areas in progress so we'll
we'll continue to to look at that
um
just in terms of resources and and time
spent was basically spending broadly in
line with with our planned plan time
um
in terms of our outputs um
slightly below target at the moment in
terms of reports
um although noted there's been few
activities that we've done undertaken
instead of issuing a final report an
example is around schools i.t for
instance where
we we took a decision to send a
questionnaire to all the trafford
schools around their i.t arrangements
and gathering gathering
feedback from that and with the views of
lessons learned looking at the
processes in place
salford audit who helped with our it
audit work we'll be looking at the the
responses received and that will also
that will help inform our work for 22 3
around that area and we'll probably go
out and pick a few samples of schools
and and look at arrangements but with a
view that can be lessons learned across
across the board in terms of the
providing guidance to all the schools
um
appendix 2 page 101
lists the reports issued and
all the work planned as well
number of reviews are in progress
through this quarter
and we're also discussing with each
director around any reviews that haven't
yet started and whether they do start
during the current quarter or we look at
prioritizing them um for the year ahead
so as i say the committee will get the
copy of the audit plan for approval um
at the meeting in march
um just just looking at priorities for
the current quarter
uh we're in
issuing a number of final reports
particularly for instance those ones are
highlighted as draft and a number of
other reviews during the period we'll
keep progressing those
we'll also give a strategic risk update
to the committee
to the next meeting as well
in terms of our staffing as well we're
also we're in process of a recruitment
exercise to
fill a vacancy following an internal
promotion
um
so then i'll give an update on the final
quarter along with the annual updates
the annual reports at a future meeting
so happy to take any questions
thanks mark any questions anybody
counselor boys
yeah just on on your comment about a
questionnaire going out to schools about
it was that was that in relation to
like it network staff usage or pupil
usage of whatever tablets and
chromebooks whatever or both or a net
covered procurement presumably i'm
asking for a point of view like
i'm a governor of two schools and the
school one of them certainly seems to
have a sort of totally
independent discussion about going out
and getting quotations for whatever it
is they decide they want so
so it's quite uh i mean it's if it's a
few months since i've read through each
element it's quite a wide ranging
document around particularly around
security
and arrangements in the school
uh
in terms of hardware software and it
would impact some things like yeah
acceptable use policies for
that would extend so yeah pupils as well
it's quite a while i'm happy to i'll i
can send a
copy of it through
for information um and we've had a very
good response to it as well i think
there's at least 50 schools have
responded to it um
pleasing response i'm not surprised
i think that it is something which
it's out with the normal experience of
teachers who are basically managing and
running the school isn't it unless
they've got somebody on the governing
body who's got you know a current
knowledge and current activity in the
i.t
market of one side or another whether
it's networks or whether it's
devices like this then they're
struggling a little bit
because they do other things like
children
i think we'll say we'll look at the
responses and take some of you about
visiting a selection of them as well and
providing a bit more
guidance and but sending some sort of
doing some sort of lessons learned and
sharing good practice across the board
thanks mark any more questions for
anybody
thanks very much can we move on then to
item 10 the work program which is again
it's mark
thank you
uh yeah the work program so it just
shows you the uh agenda for
the march meeting
we did do a slight change of the agenda
because originally cyber security was
coming to this one and star were doing
march and we've just swapped them around
so cyber security update for the uh for
the next meeting together with all the
other items listed
thanks any questions
just for information really but anyone
wants to
suggest any additions i'm sure
councillor mitchell just very briefly uh
it's nice to hear that
the council is being very reactive
and trying to actually
cure the um the problems which are being
inflicted upon us
in this way
but
i'm more frightened now than i have ever
been
on the actual future of trafford and i
just i'm not going to be here to to
to see it through
so i am very much reliant on uh graham
and his
wonderful
staff and also the help of our auditors
and also of our chairman thank you
[Music]
thanks man thank you mitchell
oh well
some of us might be in the same boat as
you we might not be we're here to see
major changes but maybe we will i don't
know any any other questions
we won't take a vote on that
no i don't think so though
some of us might have to declare an
interest we did that yeah
okay any further
queries about the work program
no thanks very much well that's uh
itunes 11 is urgent business i've not
been informed of any matters of urgent
business
and i've just realized that it's uh it's
my opinion whether they are urgent
anyway but it would not be any
so
that's the end of the meeting everybody
thanks very much for your attendance
thank you if you could just record if we
could just record our thanks for the
offices and um agencies who've uh
contributed that's really really helpful
thank you
i'm sorry i always tell them for granted
is